Hong Kong police have used tear gas as
new clashes with protesters broke out
across the city
police say protesters ignored warnings
to leave and hurled bricks at officers
before they responded by firing the gas
it's the tenth weekend of increasingly
violent protests in the territory the
demonstrations began in opposition to a
law that would have permitted
extradition to mainland China and
expanded into calls for more democracy
and greater autonomy from China aw
Phoebe Kong is in Hong Kong Phoebe hi
what's been happening where you are now
I'm right I'm also a police station in
downtown Hong Kong as you can see there
are still some of the police vans
parking right behind me at the crossroad
of this heart of Hong Kong downtown City
and because just hours ago police have
started that clearance operation where
they have deployed rounds of tear gas to
disperse protesters across different
district in Hong Kong including where I
am right now and so far most of the
protesters they have left here and they
have moved to another district to
continue their demonstration there is
and one of the usual tactics they're
using now they're stationed obsessional
protests around a different district in
Hong Kong they are not things they will
one protest area where they move very
quickly whenever police came to them and
so this is the situation right now and
both of the police officers and the
protesters they're getting more familiar
with the tactics of each other's their
tactics so both sides they react in a
much faster way right now and protesters
have also been blocking what's normally
a really busy Airport is travel being
disrupted there as well
well the International Airport in Hong
Kong remains functional so far despite
that the fact that the protesters have
staged a peaceful sit-in assembly for
the third day in a row already for the
whole weekend hundreds if not thousands
of them sitting peacefully at the
terminal of the Hong Kong International
Airport and their aim is to disseminate
their message and their demands to the
governance to the two different tourists
around the world and they want a force
to be heard on the international stage
and that's why that's the reason why
they chose our Airport as the
destination of the protests and that is
one of the most peaceful rallies one of
the peaceful actions protesters have
taken in this movement so far and they
are showing that depends they're not
going to back down although our clashes
have been happening on the street but
now some of them they want to check out
take a more peaceful approach to to
address the issue to the rest of the
world no end in sight by the looks of it
at the moment thanks Phoebe Kong for
that update